Ahozabillahiminashshaytanahrajeem bismillahirahmanirahim Allahum ma rabbana lakalhamdukulluhu wa la kalmajdukulluhu wa biyadital khairukulluhu wa ilaika yar ja'ul umurukulluhu alaaniyatuhu wa sirruhu subhana dil aizati wal jabruti subhana al hayalladila yamutu
Subhan Al Hayyal Haleem Subhan Al Ba'is Al Waris Subhan Al Azim Al A'Azam Tabarak Allahu Ahsan Al Khaliqeen Alhamdulillah Alladhi Anzala Ala Abdihil Kitab Walam Yaja Allahu Aywajah Walhamdulillah Alladhi Lam Yat Tahiz Waladan Walam Yakun Lahu Sharikun Filmulk Walam Yakun Lahu Walium Minna Zulli Waqabbir Hu Tagbirah Walhamdulillah
Alladinahmaduhu wa nasta'ainuhu wa nastaghfiruhu wa nuqminu bihi wa na tawakkal wa 'alai Wa na 'uzubillahi min shuroori anfusina wa min sayyy ati 'amalina Man yahdihillahu fala mudillala Wa man yudlilhu fala hadi Allah Wa nashhaduan la ilaha illa Allah Wahdahula sharikalah Wa nashhadu Anna Muhammadan Abdullahi wa rasulih
Arsalahullahu ta'ala bilhuda waleen al-haq liyuzhirahu ala deeni kulli wa kafa billahi shaheeda Wa na shalu anna mawlana aliibnabi taalib wasiyuhu wa waziru fa salallahu alayhim wa ala alayhim wa sallimuum tasliman kasiran kasira Allahum mala 'ilmalana illa ma alamtana inna kaantal alimul Hakeem Allahum ma alimna bima yanfa'ana wa yanfa'na bima alamtana
Allahum ma inna na'uzu bika min ail min la yanfa wa min kalbin la yaksha wa min aimin la tadma wa min naqsin la tashfa Fa'amma ba'adiyakulo subhanahu wa ta'ala fi kitabihil kareem ba'adana kula azubillahi min ash shaytana rajim bismillahir Rahmanu Rahim Rabbish Rahli sadri wa yaserli amri wahlul uqdatam mil lisani yaf kahu kawli Allahum mathabit na'indal maawtibila ilaha ilallah wallahum ma jaalna minal ladina amanu amilos taalihat
Wa tawa saou bil haq wa tawa saou bil sabr ameen ya rabbil alameen once again assalamu alaikum wa rahmatullahi wa barakatu.
Inshallah today we're going to look at the linguistic meaning of the word Rab the root for the word Rab is actually Rababa okay the word the root word for Rab is actually Rababa
and so what the Arabs?
Do is that they combine the two bars at the end and they put a Shadda on top of it right that crown at the top that's called the Shadda so they just put that.
And then it basically becomes Rabb so that is just how you know how the root word works for this now if you look at the English translation of the word Rabb you'll find that it is generally translated as Lord
And I don't really understand what the word Lord means.
The only Lord I know of is the Lord of the Rings.
So, Lord is not a good translation for the word Harab in the eyes of the Arab linguist because it does not reveal the true meaning and the power of this word.
So, let's begin by understanding Rab from a linguistic perspective.
The first thing to know is that the word Rab
is a composite word, just like the word ilah that we studied in the previous session.
In the previous session, we learned that the word ilah is not exclusive to Allah, right?
It can be used for many other entities in our lives.
Similarly, the word Arab is also not exclusive to Allah, okay?
It has several linguistic implications.
this word Arab is used for Allah but it can also be used for people you know human beings and things other than Allah just like the word ila ila can be used for Allah is used for Allah but then it can be used for other things as well similarly the word Arab can be used for people it can be used for parents for teachers for guardians you know so there are many different ways in which the word Arab is used in classical Arabic
So that's the first thing I want you to understand, that Rab is not specific to Allah.
It can be used for human beings and it can be used for other things as well, okay?
Now let's understand what does the word Rab mean.
The classical definition of the word Rab is ar-rabbu hu al-maliku was sayyidu wal-murabbi wal-murshadu wal-munaymu wal-qayyimu
A true Rabb is someone who is six things.
Or I can say Allah as Rabb is six things.
He is Malik, He is Sayyad, He is Murabbi, He is Murshad, He is Muna'im and He is Qayyam.
And the interesting thing here is that He is all these six things at the same time.
This is the part that really is important.
The meaning of the word Rab is the combination of all these six meanings at the same time.
And this will become clear.
So let's look at each of these meanings individually.
Let's look at the first one.
The first meaning is Malik, which means owner.
Someone who has ownership of something or someone is called a Rab.
and that thing that he owns is called milk okay so there's malik and what he owns is milk this is not the English milk that cows produce in Arabic milk or milqiya it means property and the owner of that property is called malik okay now do we own things in life?
do we own phones, iPads, computers, cars, houses?
Yes.
So, that makes us Malik as well.
Right?
And because owner is one of the definitions of the word Rab, so by virtue of that ownership it makes us Rab as well.
You understand?
So, I am the Malik of my Kaar and the Kaar is my Milqiya.
You see?
So, do teachers have some ownership over their students?
Sure.
Do parents have ownership over young children?
Yeah.
I mean, despite how the kids might feel that, you know, it's my life, mom.
You can't tell me what to do.
You don't own me.
Well, despite all of these sentiments, you know, that children have today, I mean, and to be fair, the sentiments we had as kids growing up, the truth is that parents have an ownership over their children until they become adults.
But do parents have ultimate and absolute ownership?
No.
Because even though parents do give birth to their children, they do not create them.
Allah created them.
Allah created the child and the parent.
Therefore ultimate and absolute ownership belongs only to Allah.
So you see where
how the generic sense of ownership becomes specific when it comes towards Allah.
Right?
So even though parents, teachers, they're all rub in the sense of the word, Allah is the absolute owner and the absolute rub of His creation.
He is Malik.
And if He is Malik, what does that make us?
It makes us His property that makes us Milqiya.
Okay?
So that's the first meaning.
The second meaning of the word can be understood by the word Sayyad which complements the previous meaning of Malik.
The word Malik meant owner whereas Sayyad it means someone who has authority.
Sayyad is the one who is in charge.
You understand the difference?
Malik is someone who has ownership
Sayyad is the one who has authority.
So why are we...
why am I using...
why do they use separate out these two things?
Is it possible to own something and then not have complete authority over it?
Sure, it's possible.
For example, I own my car but do I still have to get it registered?
Do I still have to get it inspected every year?
Do I still have to drive within speed limits?
Do I have to drive it on the road?
Can I just drive it on the sidewalk if I, you know, feel like it?
No.
Not unless I'm in Pakistan.
So, even though I own my car, I do not necessarily have complete authority over it.
You understand?
And the reverse of this is also true.
I may have complete authority over something
I may be able to do whatever I please with something, but I may not have complete ownership of it.
Like for example, the computer in my office.
I can do whatever I want with the software that is installed on it.
I can install new stuff.
I can uninstall old stuff.
You know, nobody's going to stop me or question me about that.
But do I own that computer?
No.
My company owns it, right?
So you understand the difference?
I can own things
but not have complete authority over it or I can have complete authority over something but not necessarily have ownership of it.
Right?
But Allah as Rabb, He has absolute ownership and He has complete authority.
He has both at the same time.
He can do whatever he wants, whenever he wants.
You know with this property because we are all his property.
If he wants to burn it, he can burn it.
If he wants to tear it apart, he can tear it apart.
If he wants to drown it, toss it, discard it.
He can do anything he wants at his will.
You and I do not get to question him about it.
Why?
Because he has complete ownership
And he has complete authority over us and everything else in the universe.
And even if we do complain and cry about it, guess what?
It makes no difference to him.
He does not care.
Because he is owner, he and we are his property.
You know when parents ground their children, if I take my daughter's phone away,
I mean she can cry and complain as much as she wants, but she's not getting it back because I am her Malik.
And in that context, she and her phone are my milqiya.
I bought her that phone.
And so if our crying and grumbling doesn't get us anywhere with our own parents who are limited in their capacities as Rabb, so it surely will not make a difference to the one who is
the absolute and ultimate rock.
Right?
So this is something we really have to understand that we are creation.
He is the creator.
He is the owner.
We are property.
And what we constantly seem to forget is that He is not the one on trial.
We are.
I mean we've got it completely backwards.
Today mankind has put Allah in the stands
and taken the seat of the judge and we shamelessly question his every move you know if you are so powerful then why don't you eliminate evil from this world if you are so loving and merciful then you know how could you do this to me I prayed to you why did I not get that job or that promotion right I'm a good person I pay my taxes I pay my Zakat
I brush my teeth twice every day.
Why did you do this to me?
You see?
So we've got it completely backwards.
The reality is that he is the judge.
He is the Malik.
He is the Sayyid.
We are his property and his subjects.
He has every right to question us.
We have absolutely no right to question him.
This is just based on the principle of ownership and property.
Nobody can argue with this.
And this is why I find this so amazing about Allah is that He actually allowed us to understand the wisdom of His design.
You know through the Quran and His messengers.
He did not create us as robots.
He did not create us like, I don't know, a tree.
He gave us intellect.
So I feel that is an incredible act of mercy and generosity on His part because He is not obligated to do anything for us.
the one who subjugated the entire solar system is definitely capable of you know subjugating us but he did not do that and this is what I find so amazing about Allah as this powerful you know being that has complete authority and ownership of us right he's not there to service but he does it anyway because that is what a true Rab does
anyway so I hope it's clear the difference between you know these distinctions between ownership and authority right so that's the first two things Malik and Sayyid okay the third one is now this is a very powerful word Murabbi this is someone who basically ensures growth alright Murabbi is someone who ensures growth
Someone who takes care of something, who nurtures something so that it can grow, that's a Murabbi.
Now, is it possible for us to own something, have authority over it, but not take good care of it?
Sure.
You know, backyards in many houses.
That's a good example.
People own cars but they never get them serviced.
We own our bodies and yet we abuse it.
We have ownership and authority over our bodies but rarely do people take good care of their bodies.
So it is possible to have ownership and authority over something
but that does not necessarily mean that we will also take good care of it.
Understand?
A Rabb is someone who not only owns, who not only has complete authority over what he owns, but then he also takes complete care of it.
He ensures its proper growth.
He nurtures it and this process of taking care of
one's property and nurturing it is called Tarbiya.
It's called Tarbiya and this is a phenomenon we find everywhere in the world.
This is not just specific to humans.
You know, Allah placed this design in His creations.
There's...
a poet says...
...
The depth of the ocean nurtures the white clear pearl.
So, he calls the ocean a rab because it helps develop that pearl within its shell.
A tree is also called a rab because it nurtures the fruit it bears.
So, there are all these different kinds of tarbiya that we find in the world.
And the concept of Tarbiya, and this is really important, the concept of Tarbiya is all about setting limits, setting boundaries.
You cannot have Tarbiya without setting boundaries.
That's what Tarbiya is.
The Tarbiya of a plant would be to take care of it, you know, watering it at the right time, making sure it gets enough sunlight, protecting it from too much sunlight.
protecting it from insects, from bugs.
Right?
So in other words, Tarbiya is a bunch of do's and don'ts.
It's a bunch of do's and don'ts that apply until the plant matures into a tree and starts bearing fruit.
You understand?
If you just leave the plant to grow by itself, that's not Tarbiya.
Because you're not setting limits, you're not setting boundaries.
Similarly, Tarbiya of children is taking care of their physical needs.
Their diets, their clothing, their mental needs, educating them, protecting them.
It's a bunch of do's and don'ts that are applied to a child for their nurturing.
Tarbiya is basically monitoring their progress from birth until they mature into a healthy, sound, decent human being.
From a physical point of view, from a psychological point of view, from a social point of view, that's all tarbiyatul awlad.
Now, is tarbiyya a quick and easy process?
Or is it a very long, very time-consuming process?
It is very hard work, isn't it?
In fact, it is the most difficult process there is.
It's a never-ending, thankless, full-time job.
Right?
And parents do that and this is why when we recite at-tahiyat in every prayer, what do we say at the end of at-tahiyat?
We say, Allahum maqfir li O Allah forgive me.
Wa li walidaiya and my parents.
And have mercy on them just as they had mercy on me during my period of Tarbiyya when I was young.
Right?
And this is such a beautiful statement because in this statement we find the primary ingredient of Rububiyya.
Allahum maghfili
Forgive me, forgive my parents and have mercy on them just as they had mercy on me.
So what we're learning is that the primary ingredient of Rububiya, of Tarbiya, of nurturing is mercy.
The primary component of Rububiya is mercy.
If there is no mercy, then there can be no Rububiya.
And what is mercy?
It is a combination of love, care, and concern.
It's a combination of love, care, and concern.
That's what rububia is made of.
Have you ever seen people, you know, who shower all this TLC on plants?
Like they'll actually spray each individual leaf with water and then clean them gently with a soft cloth.
Right?
That kind of love and that kind of care
with that level of gentleness is imamate of Rububiyya.
It is not harshness, it is not beating, it is not you know psychological, emotional, physical abuse, it is not guilt tripping into submission, it is love, it is patience, it is kindness.
That's the Islamic way of Rububiyya.
I mean this is contrary to what we see in movies and society today
you know but the reality is that the Islamic way of Rububiya has always been Rahmah, it has always been mercy and the proof of that is the life of Rasulullah sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
I mean just think about this right, our Prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam he took the most vicious people, he took the most barbaric people and without a single slap, without a single taunt
without a single sarcastic remark, without a single insult, he turned them into Radi Allahu Anhu, he turned them into Rahmatullah Alaihi, the greatest titles possible for a human being Radi Allah Anhu.
I mean we don't mention the name of these Sahaba without saying Radi Allah Anhu, without saying Rahmatullah Alaihi and our Prophet did that.
How?
with his love, with his gentleness, with his kindness, forgiveness, patience, with his akhlaq.
That's Rububiyya.
And sometimes harshness is necessary in Rububiyya.
There's no question about that.
But behind that harshness, the sentiment is still Rahma.
It's not frustration, it's not anger, it is still Rahma.
It is to guide the person.
Because you have tried love, you have tried kindness, it's not working but you have to make sure that this person does the right thing so now you resort to harshness but even behind that harshness your primary ingredient is still love.
that is Raboobiyah and Rasulallah's life is the perfect example of that Raboobiyah and you know and what did he ask in return is very interesting.
Rasulallah after devoting 23 years of his life to our Tarbiyya, have you guys ever heard the last Khutba, the Hajjatul-Wida, the last sermon of the Prophet when he was returning from Hajj?
That is something really incredible.
In that he says
he says many things, but one of the things he says towards the end when he's ending his khutbah, he says, Ya ummati laa tusawwidawajhiyo malqiyama O my people, do not embarrass me before Allah on the Day of Judgment.
That's what he says in the end.
Ya ummati laa tusawwidawajiyo malqiyama Do not embarrass me before Allah on the Day of Judgment.
You know, when a result does not meet expectations,
If majority of the students fail in a class, doesn't the principal question the teacher?
What's going on?
Why are there so many failures in your class?
And our Prophet after 23 years of service and Tarbiya asked us for one thing in return.
Do not embarrass me before Allah on the Day of Judgment.
And so may Allah make us among those who makes our, you know, who make our Prophet proud on that day.
So that is Rububiyya, right?
And which is comes from the act of Rububiyya is Tarbiyya and the main ingredient of that Tarbiyya is love, care and concern which is Rahma, right?
The fourth meaning of the word Arab comes from Murshad.
He is the one who sets things in the right direction.
The one who sets us on the right path, puts us to proper use.
That's a Murshat.
The guide, right?
The word Murshat comes from the word Rushd, which in classical Arabic means to ripen.
You know when a fruit ripens, it's the final stage for a fruit.
That's why Rusht also means rationality, it also means reason, it also means maturity because those are the final stages of intellect.
So Murshad is the one who takes something in its raw form, works on it with Rahma, with love, continues working on it, it gets involved in its Tarbiya until it ripens, till it matures.
and then he puts it to proper use.
He sets it in the right direction.
This is a murshid.
So let's say if you have a teacher who trains you let's say in computer sciences and then also finds you a job so that you can now apply what you've learned that would be a murshid.
And a murshid is not someone who just trains you to maturity and then leaves you to rot.
He actually designs a path for you.
He guides you forward from your point of maturity.
You know he provides you with the opportunity to practice what you've learned.
So that you and others can benefit from what you've learned.
That's a mushad.
You understand?
So what we're learning here is that Allah as Rabb is not only someone who owns us.
who has complete authority over us, who nurtures us with love, care and concern but he is also the one to create opportunities for us so that we can put our training to use.
He trains us by putting people in our path that will help us grow and develop.
He's the one who find the perfect friend for you.
That friend who is going to help you grow and mature.
And then he will use that friend to guide you in putting that training to use.
By becoming good friends to other people.
That's what a mushad does.
And this is something even parents and teachers cannot do at times.
You know, they will complete the tarbiyah of their children but then they cannot always put them to proper use.
You know, kids have to find their own path.
But Allah as Rabb, He goes the extra mile and He sets us on the right path after our training has been completed.
That's a mushad, subhanallah.
Alright, so that's the fourth meaning.
The next meaning comes from the word Munahim.
The word Munahim is used for the one who bestows gifts, the one who gives blessings.
It comes from the root word Niham or Nihamah which means gift or blessing.
We don't have slavery today but imagine for a second that if we owned a slave
Right?
Now it is one thing to own a slave and it is an entirely different thing to take care of that slave, to nurture that slave, to put that slave to proper use and then on top of everything bestow gifts upon the slave.
And the word Ni'amah suggests gifts and benefits that are on top of what he deserves.
Remember gifts are not deserved things.
Gift is not something you deserve.
Gift by definition you know they're always beyond what is deserved.
Isn't that true?
It is an expression of the love and mercy of the benefactor.
If you deserved it then that is salary.
That is a pay.
That is an earning.
It's not a gift.
You understand the difference?
Now interestingly the Arabic word for 'Naam' which means 'yes' also comes from the same root word as 'blessing'.
Why?
Because what's the natural human response to receiving blessing?
It's 'Naam' 'yes'.
Right?
Isn't that interesting?
And this is why I love this language.
Every word is so perfectly connected.
Every variation, every derivative is so perfectly connected to its root.
Anyway, so now imagine that you own a slave or an animal.
Let's say a goat, right?
You own a goat and so you take care of it, right?
Because it's your property.
But you don't buy gifts.
You're not going to buy your goat jewelry, right?
Why?
Because you don't need to.
It's a goat.
It's part of your property.
So in the old days, slaves were no different than a goat or an animal, right?
They were barely taken care of, let alone given gifts.
Who is Allah?
He is Malik and He is Sayyid, right?
He is our absolute owner with complete authority over us, which makes us His milqiya, His property.
You see that?
he is the shepherd we are the sheep but Allah as Rabb is an owner who not only takes good care of his property who not only has complete authority and control over it who not only ensures its growth to maturity with love, kindness, concern who not only looks after it, protects it
sustains it, puts it on the right path but then on top of all of that he bestows numerous undeserving generous gifts upon it.
Think about that for a second.
Allah as our absolute master does not owe us anything and this is a very difficult concept for a lot of people to grasp because we just think Allah owes us a lot.
For some reason we just believe that, you know, He is supposed to do all of this stuff for us.
No, He is Malik.
He is Al-Malik.
He is As-Sayyad.
He doesn't need to do anything for us.
He does not owe us anything.
Therefore anything and everything he gives us, it has to be a gift.
He is not obligated to give us anything.
I did not do anything to deserve my eyesight.
I did not do anything to pay for my hands.
How much would you charge if I asked you to sell both your eyes to me?
Forget both eyes.
How much would you sell me one eye for?
How much would you sell your hands for?
How much is your ability to walk worth to you?
We just cannot put a price on these things.
These are priceless gifts.
So Allah gave us all these precious gifts but He did not just give them to us.
Gifts, even though are an act of generosity, there is a whole philosophy behind gifts which InshaAllah we'll talk about when we talk, you know, when we discuss Haydnasirat al-Mustaqeen.
But gifts, you know, there is a purpose for a gift and He says that He will question us about these gifts on the Day of Judgment.
On that day we will be asked about the greatest gift of all.
What is the greatest gift of all?
Iman.
Right?
The word na'een is the superlative form of na'am or ni'am and it means the greatest gift of all.
What is that greatest gift of all that has been given to us?
Iman, faith.
That is the ultimate gift.
On the day of judgment, Allah will ask us about our iman which is the greatest blessing of all.
Otherwise, what was the purpose of giving us all these gifts and making us different from animals?
Right?
If I give you a gift, I expect you to use it for the purpose that I gave it to you for.
So, if that was not the case, animals have eyes, animals have ears, right?
But they don't have the intellect that we have.
They don't have iman.
So the idea of all these gifts and intellect most of all is so that we can develop iman.
So that we can become different from animals.
So that we can see creation, reflect upon it and then recognize him and try to get closer to him.
You understand?
So now we're learning that Allah as Rab is someone who not only owns us
who not only has ultimate authority over us, who not only trains us, nurtures us with love, care and concern, kindness, patience until the point we reach maturity, who not only puts us on our chosen path, but then he also showers us with tons and tons of undeserving gifts.
basically he helps us with all these gifts so that to make our path easier to make us comfortable to make it pleasurable that's a Rabb I mean how powerful is this word I mean just think about that right our understanding of Rabb is so limited until we actually get into the linguistics of the word so I hope this is really giving you the power of this word Rabb
And the final meaning of the word Arab comes from Qayyam and Qayyam is the one that makes sure that things stay together.
He makes sure that things do not fall apart.
The one who has his constant attention and focus on things.
Because when you are not constantly focused on something that is important what happens?
You drop the ball.
Right?
Things fall apart.
People who enjoy gardening, they know that some plants are extremely delicate.
If you don't take care of them for even one day, they will die.
Some people have fish for pets.
I mean, if you forget to feed them even for a single day, what happens?
Nemo kebab for dinner, right?
right I mean ladies if you leave your house and attend it for one day what happens right so you understand what Qayyam does Qayyam is the sustainer the maintainer the one who constantly focuses and keeps his attention on things the one who never drops the ball who cannot afford to drop the ball that meaning is also embedded in the word Fraub
That's why Allah says in the Quran, Allahu la ilaha illahu al-hayyul qayyum.
Allah is the only ilah who is al-hayy, who is the giver of life and he is al-qayyum, the one who then also maintains that life by his constant attention on things.
The word Qayyum is again the superlative form of Qayyum, the one who constantly sustains, who constantly maintains, who never takes a break.
Right?
Qayyum, you know, the superlative form it's actually showing that there is no break, there's never a loss of attention.
so in other words I'm not alive because I take care of myself you know one breath to the next is not because I eat healthy and because I exercise or if because I follow a good diet or because I live in a healthy environment that is not why I'm alive the only reason I am alive is because Allah allows me to be alive because he sustains me not because of my efforts you understand
There are plenty of ways I can cease to exist in a second.
Just crossing the road.
One little earthquake, one snow blizzard, that's it.
You know that Indian actress, Sridevi, who just died?
I mean, perfectly healthy woman, drowned in a bathtub.
She probably had lots of plans for the next day, just as I do, just as you do.
I'm sure she had a lot of short-term goals, long-term goals, right?
All gone, ****.
We exist because the Qayyam allows us to exist.
So we are completely and constantly dependent on Allah.
Another thing in this ayah, you know, Allahu la ilaha illa walhayil Qayyum, we see two attributes of Allah that are mentioned, Al-Hayy and Al-Qayyum.
The one who gives life and the constant maintainer.
Now why are those attributes used together?
Every ayat in the Quran when two attributes are used together they're very connected.
So why are these two used together?
Because the one who gives life also knows how to sustain it.
In other words, only the one who gives life knows how to sustain it.
He knows how long to sustain it, what stages and steps to take it through, how and when to end it, what happens after it ends.
That entire plan of action for each individual creation, not just for human beings, all creation, all of creation.
That entire blueprint from beginning to end is already and completely planned out by the Qayyum.
That is the difference between Qayyum and Qayyum, right?
Qayyum has it all planned out.
Allah is not making this up as he goes.
The destiny of every single creation, the plan of every single creation's progress has been already determined.
He's already thought about everything from beginning to end.
That's part of the meaning of Qayyum to have a complete perfect plan.
You can start something or maintain something without a plan, can you?
When you decide to start a business, you don't just choose what business you're going to do.
by playing I don't know you know like rock paper scissors.
I mean you have to have an entire business plan right?
What your initial investment is going to be, how will you keep the business afloat, how will you grow the business, cost analysis, expense analysis, budget allocations right?
You plan the whole nine years and you do all of this before you actually even begin the business.
So you think Allah just created all of this without a plan?
Not possible, right?
So those are the six meanings that come together to give us the definition of the word Rabb.
So now let's look all of this together.
Rabb is someone who is Malik, who has absolute ownership over his property.
At the same time he is Sayyid he has complete and unconditional authority.
At the same time he is a Murabbi he ensures growth, takes care of us, nurtures us, protects us with love, care and concern and mercy.
At the same time he is Murshad who brings us to physical and spiritual maturity and then sets us on his straight path.
puts us to proper use, gives us the opportunity to practice what we've learned.
At the same time He is Muna'im who showers us with undeserving and numerous gifts and blessings.
And at the same time He is Qayyim who sustains us for the extent of our duration.
Allah as our Rabb is the sum of all of these meanings all at the same time.
He is not one of these things at different times of our lives.
He is all of these things and he is all of these things at the same time.
His ownership includes his authority, which includes his nurturing, which includes his guidance and direction, which includes his blessings, which includes his sustenance, his provisions, his maintenance all at the same time.
SubhanAllah.
So now
I hope you have a much clearer understanding of what the word harab means and the point of learning these words linguistically, you know, ilah, Allah, harab, all of this, is to start seeing Allah in a different light.
Because we all have our own understanding of, you know, Allah, but what these words do is that they help us remove the fog and, you know, make things clear for us.
Okay, so this is what Allah is and this is what He's doing for us.
and that what that does is it helps us determine what we have to be like right and so you know to conclude I want to tie this understanding of Rab that that I explained today with one of the earlier sessions in which I talked about this man of pure essence if you remember someone from the Ulil Al Baap who is deeply reflecting on the creations of the heavens and the earth
Right?
And he's deeply reflecting on the conflict between the night and day.
So, in that, he says...
Inna fi khal kis samawati wal kanth waqtila fil laili wann nahar la ayatin li ulil al baab.
Right?
that indeed in the creation of the heavens and the earth and the conflict between night and day there are clear signs for the people of pure essence and I explain each of these words in a linguistically in quite a few depth in those sessions and these are the people that are constantly reflecting upon the creations of the heavens and the earth whether they are sitting down whether they are standing up whether they are lying down basically all the time
And they are in deep reflection upon these creations of the heaven and the earth.
And then he says, at the end of his conclusion he says, After recognizing that there has to be a creator for the heavens and the earth and for himself,
Look at this.
The word he uses for that creator is Rabb.
You see that?
Because when he reflected on the creations of the heaven and the earth, that is what he saw.
He saw an absolute owner
He saw somebody who has complete authority, somebody who is nurturing and developing his creation with love, care, kindness and mercy, who is setting everything to its purpose, who is showering every creation with numerous undeserving gifts and blessings and who is sustaining, maintaining, providing for them continuously without losing focus on them through the entire timeline of their existence.
This is why he said, Rabbana maa khalakhtaha da batila.
Our Rabb we did not create all of this without a purpose.
You did not create all of this without a purpose.
And this was an extremely beautiful and a very appropriate conclusion drawn by this person of intellect because Allah validates that conclusion in his revelation.
What is the very first ayah that was revealed to Rasulullah ?
Ikrab bismi rabbikalladi khalaq.
Recite with the name of your Rabb who created you.
Not Ikrab bismillahilladi khalaq.
he could have said that right but look at this in this very first verse just think about this very first verse is being revealed to the prophet and Allah is introducing himself to his messenger for the very first time and what does he say when you introduce yourself how do you do that do you use your name or do you use your attribute
If I met you for the very first time in your life and I said Assalamu Alaikum, I'm a teacher or Assalamu Alaikum, I can do 200 push-ups, what would you say?
You'll be like Wa Alaikum Assalam, you're also a weirdo, right?
Because that's not normal.
When you introduce yourself, you always use your name.
So, I would imagine that Allah should have said Read with the name of Allah who created you.
Right?
No, but He says Read in the name of your Rabb who created you.
Allah chose to introduce Himself as Rabb.
Now, what does this tell you?
When I introduce myself as a teacher, what am I telling you?
How am I characterizing myself?
I'm characterizing myself as a teacher.
In other words what I'm saying is that my being a teacher is way more important to me than all my other attributes including my name.
Now does Allah have shortage of attributes?
No.
But even though Allah is glorious beyond comprehension, he is magnificent beyond comprehension, he is powerful beyond comprehension.
What he's saying to Rasulullah sallallahu alaihi wa sallam and to us by extension is that when I interact with you the most important relationship that's going to exist between us is that of Rabb.
That is how I want you to think of me.
Not as Jaleel, not as Azim, not as Qawi, not as Kabir, not as Mutakabbir, but as what?
As Rab.
SubhanAllah.
I mean, we just take this for granted, you know, we just assume a lot of this stuff, but I just want you to take a moment to really let this sink in, just reflect on this.
When a king introduces himself,
Does he introduce himself in a humble way?
Does he say oh I'm your neighbor I got this you know big house next door.
I'm your dad's friend.
I'm your caretaker.
Does the king say that?
No.
He says I'm your king.
Knew before me.
Bow down to me right?
That's how a king introduces himself.
If Allah
chose to do that in the Quran, let's say Allah introduced Himself in that way, would it befit Him?
Would that have been okay to do so?
Would that have been acceptable for us slaves and properties?
Absolutely! But what word does He choose to use instead?
Rab.
And now that you actually understand the meaning and the Rahma and the love behind this word Rab, can you imagine how important this word must be to him?
And so after understanding the meaning, the real meaning of this word, can you appreciate the kind of love, the kind of loving relationship he wishes to have with his creation?
and this is very important to understand I mean you know that it was not a coincidence that he introduced himself as Rabb in the first verse this is very important from a thematic you know point of view as well because if you look at the sequence of revelation in the very first verse he says right recite
in the name of your Rabb who created you.
But what is the last verse that was revealed to Rasulullah in the Quran?
Sequentially.
On this day I have perfected your religion for you and I have completed my blessings on you and I have selected Islam as the way of life for you.
...
and then he says like you know that's the completion of the verse but then he ends the verse by saying ...
have no doubt about it Allah is all forgiving and all merciful here he does not use the word Arab, you see that?
because the entire Quran is an explanation of who Allah is all his attributes and everything but he ends it by using his name.
Of course he's used his name everywhere else in the Quran but it's really interesting to me that in the first verse sequentially he starts with Rabb and ends with Fa'in Allaha Wafoor Raheem that's the last statement of that was revealed to the Prophet have no doubt about it that Allah is all forgiving and all merciful
begins the revelation with the word Rab and he ends it with his name Allah right which is which which interestingly exactly matches the pattern of Bismillah Rahman Rahim in that you have the name Allah followed by the two attributes of mercy Rahman and Rahim and how does he end revelation the constantly forgiving the constantly loving
He begins his message with his intense and constant love and mercy.
He ends his message with his constant forgiveness and his constant mercy.
SubhanAllah.
...